it was a shared love of books that
brought Derek young and Ramon to lark
young together many years ago my
experiences were going to poetry
readings were going to bookstores
hanging out and talking about different
subjects with his business or social
justice before long the two were married
and now they fulfilled their dream of
owning their own bookstore the duo
carefully selects each title to reflect
the richness of the african-american
community culture has been something
that's a part of our whole life my
husband and I it's been important to
share our culture to share our history
and to now have a space that really has
the faces that reflect ours the stories
that reflect our our legacy Anish focus
like this is unique to local
independently owned bookstores like
mahogany books it's a reason they're
thriving even as other brick-and-mortar
retailers have suffered in this age of
online shopping it appears that
independent bookstores are bucking the
trend the American Booksellers
Association reports a 50% increase in
such bookstores in the last decade and
an increase in sales of books I mean
real books the kind that you can ruffle
through and smell that's on the rise for
25 years people have been talking about
the death of print but it it really does
have an enduring quality richard reyes
Gavilan is executive director of the DC
Public Library he says while patrons
continue to check out ebooks in large
numbers the high prices publishers
charge libraries to license those books
make their offerings limited libraries
have to pay sometimes five or six times
as much as you would pay for an e-book
we would have to so if you're paying $10
for an e-book we might pay 60 70 or 80
dollars for an e-book overall eBook
sales in the US market have been on the
decline since 2015 author Donita
Roundtree Green says that's not
surprising
she says physical books are just as
important to a community as physical
bookstores people want to read books we
want to be able to have relationships
with authors and people who are really
doing
things and opening our eyes to things we
want a relationship with with those
people and that only really comes from a
printed book and maybe a discussion and
a place to have all of those things
housed together some things just can't
be replaced
Heidi Joe Castro al Jazeera Washington